ez nagyon érdekes íy egyből az első
gondolatom ezzel kapcsolatban az volt
hogy mi mennyire szimmetrikus mennyire
szépen rendeződik hogy meleg hideg meleg
hideg így egymás után és genetika a
személyiségünkkel összefüggnek ezek a
színek tehát érdekes módon jellemzőink
vannak
személyiségben amik megnyilvánulnak a
színeinkben és fordí hogy látsz eg ilyen
összefüggésst például hogy a hideg szín
az tegyük fel az introvertált
személyeknek a a asszociáci a a
színeknek a pszichológiája egy picit
bonyolult mert ugye amikor egy színre
gondolunk akkor a legjellemzőbben ugye a
a nem is a nem színeket szoktuk ilyenkor
felhozni a fehér és a fekete a nyugati
kultúrában egészen más szimbolikával
bírnak mint például az ázsiai vagy a
délkeleti kultúrában